[Applaudissements]
bonjour
bonjour a tous
je veux particulièrement rendre hommage
à ceux qui se sont levés tôt ce matin
après s'être couché
un peu plus tard hier soir
et certains méritent particulièrement
cet hommage marque tout à fait ce qu'il
fallait
jacqueline aussi est donc
temps que
merci d'être là je je veux accueillir en
votre nom richard ferrand
président de l'assemblée nationale en
vous
[Applaudissements]
en vous disant des choses assez simples
comme vous savez nous sommes richard et
moi engagé depuis plusieurs mois dans
une réflexion
d'abord que nous avons conduite à 2
et puis que nous avons peu à peu partagé
avec les principaux responsables
et puis comme vous avez vu la presse
s'en est fait l'écho
et je vais vous dire ceci qui pour moi
compte beaucoup les aventures politiques
les grandes entreprises politiques
sont aussi des aventures et des
entreprises humaines
il n'y a pas que les considérations
stratégiques tactiques
que le expertise que nous pouvons avoir
les heures et les autres de la vie
militante de la vie élective des
responsabilités parlementaires
gouvernementales
il ya quelque chose d'autre qui est
absolument essentiel qui est
le ciment de la confiance qui s'établit
parfois
pas très souvent entre les êtres humains
et je voulais vous dire que en tout cas
vu deux
de mon point de vue de mon regard
j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce cette
confiance qui s'était établi entre nous
j'aime les gens loyaux
j'aime les gens qui dissimulent pas leur
pensée
quitte à ce qu'il y ait parfois
des frictions
parfois
des frictions un peu vive
mais ceci appartient richard a un passé
lointain
nous avons
tous les deux vécu c'est moi je vois ces
semaines dont je pense qu'elles seront
fructueuses avec un grand sentiment de
responsabilité
avec l'idée que
en travaillant à ce projet
qui est un projet d'unification des deux
familles qui ont
porté
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 qui a
changé tellement de choses en france
qui a
modifié durablement le paysage
en portant cette réflexion nous ne
faisons pas de la politique au sens
partisan du terme
ne faisons pas de la politique au sens
électorale de m nous faisons de la
politique au sens civique du terne
nous sommes détenteurs
de
la légitimité d'un grands courants
démocratiques français et ce grand
courant aurait dû être créés existait
depuis longtemps ça a été la passion et
l'engagement de notre vie pour la plus
grande majorité de ceux qui sont ici
depuis des années
[Applaudissements]
nous avons pensé depuis longtemps
que
les grands courants humaniste français
l'humanisme spiritualiste d'humanisme
laïque d'humanisme
social-démocrate l'humanisme libéral
d'humanisme écologiques
étaient tous des branches du même tronc
nous avons pensé ça ici temps en temps
on est à guidel
j'ai défendu cette idée auprès de
jean-yves le drian depuis dix ou quinze
ans et puis ça n'a pas pu se faire
comme n'a pas pu se faire en 2007 la
rencontre avec michel rocard par exemple
tous avaient conscience
de ce que le le tronc commun de
conviction d'idées de valeur existait
entre jacques delors et nous
évidemment il y avait plus que de la
sympathie ou de l'amitié il y avait
quelque chose d'autre n'était détenteur
de la même de la même vision du monde
mais les impératifs partisans nous
divisaient
et l'effort pour les réunir a été un
effort considérable c'est pourquoi la
structuration de l'espace central de la
vie politique française est un devoir
civique
ainsi que que je le peux je le vis et
nous l'avons hier soir
partager ensemble pendant des heures et
je crois dans une très grande atmosphère
de
d'unités
donc
un projet qui pèse plus lourd que nous
qui dépasse de très loin
les échéances immédiates qui sont
essentiels
ne vous trompez pas qui dépasse de très
loin les intérêts des uns et des autres
qui est une responsabilité pour la
structuration de la vie politique
française
mais sans le ciment de la confiance
ça n'aurait pas pu prospérer existe et
se développe et s'enraciner se réfléchir
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai je
suis très heureux que dès ce matin dès
la première heure de nos rencontres
richard ferrand est accepté de venir
nous parler et je vous demande de
l'accueillir à la tribune
[Applaudissements]
merci chers amis du modem de
m'accueillir ce matin parmi vous
ici donc en bretagne dans cette
magnifique banlieue morbihannaise du
finistère que erwan balanant et moi
affectionnant particulièrement
je voudrais
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
véritablement de votre invitation est
aussi félicité celles et tous ceux qui à
quelque titre que ce soit en participé à
l'organisation
de ces trois jours de travail et de
retrouvailles car je sais bien que ces
événements politiques
il ya ceux qui s'expriment qui sont un
peu dans la lumière mais il ya tous ceux
qui ont rendu possibles ces rencontres
et que les choses se fassent et donc
merci à eux je voudrais évidemment salué
l'ensemble des parlementaires je
commence par eux
nanterre de l'assemblée nationale qui
sont ici mais aussi les parlementaires
européens et puis les parlementaires
bretons qui siègent dans les deux
assemblées marie-pierre gimmi erwan et
sans doute d'autres que je n'ai
peut-être pas saluer et puis bien sûr
saluer les ministres ici présents avec
lesquels nous avons toujours grand
plaisir à travailler
je voudrais aussi vous saluer toutes et
tous en nous disant que je mesure
l'effort que représente
dès le matin d'être rassemblés ici alors
même que les soirée de retrouvailles
poste confinement en donner lieu
évidemment des discussions longues
tardive mais riche mais qui rendent
parfois les réveils plus incertain alors
tout cela en vérité est aussi le signe
que la majorité est traversée par des
courants de bonne humeur de bonne humeur
de se retrouver mais de bonne humeur
aussi d'être ensemble et pour ma part
en faisant écho à ce que vient de dire
françois jeu j'ai envie de vous dire
quelques mots sur la vision d'avenir
partagé que je suis extrêmement heureux
de porter avec françois bayrou en effet
un amitié et en confiance au fond si on
fait un zoom arrière comme disent les
photographes
que voyons-nous à l'heure nous voyons
évidemment un monde globalement très
morcelé avec des doutes qui se font jour
sur la sincérité d'un certain nombre
d'alliances on voit y compris sur notre
continent européen et stéphane ces
journées ne me contredirait pas des
démocraties qui recule
et on voit dans d'autres grands pays
continent des démocraties qui sont
totalement mise à l'arrêt ou qui en tout
cas n'émerge plus
dans ce contexte là et cela rejoint
notre engagement partagé de toujours
nous avons besoin de voir l'europe se
renforcer nous avons besoin de voir la
souveraineté européenne concepts chers
au coeur du président de la république
et pas qu'à son coeur à son action nous
avons besoin de la voir se construire
cette souveraineté européenne
puisque l'on voit bien que pour peser
sur le cours du monde sur les courbes
des choses eh bien il faut que l'europe
arrive à se rassembler et à porter une
voix forte vis-à-vis des autres je puis
vous dire que pour race pour rencontrer
fréquemment
un certain nombre de présidents
d'assemblée des pays qui font partie de
l'union je me dis que l'afer est loin
d'être gagné chacun considère que
finalement c'est un club sympathique où
il est possible d'aller faire son marché
qui considère que le désir de
construction européenne sauvé une
affaire d'idéologie et pour eux c'est un
gros mot et qui considèrent que
finalement il faut être très très
pragmatique ce qui veut dire ne
s'engager sur rien mais faire ce qui est
possible à la petite semaine et quand on
commence à parler de souveraineté
européenne
d'engagements communs là on sent tout de
suite se rétracter les différentes
expressions politiques c'est dire qu'il
nous faudra collectivement une énergie
sans faille pour porter cette espérance
d'une souveraineté européenne
qui sera à l'ordre du jour de la
prochaine présidence de l'union
européenne
placez précisément sous la
responsabilité d'emmanuel macro et puis
lorsque nous regardons
la france on voit bien que il y a
beaucoup de force divisé qui veulent
diviser la france on voit bien que
l'extrême droite est prête à hystériser
ce même sans vocation tous les
questionnements et les doutes
dans une forme de surenchère haineuse et
d'autant plus haineuse qu'elle est elle
même fracturé
à l'extrême gauche on voit que tout
n'est que combat éternel nostalgique
frontale
feydeau position définitive et
d'expression sectaire un peu comme si au
fond la majorité quoi qu'elle fasse au
vais toujours tort tandis que qui ne
font rien aurait toujours raison dans le
discours
[Applaudissements]
et puis par ailleurs on nous voyons si
nous voyons à droite nous voyons à
gauche il y a un désir commun
c'est de réinstaller une france
bipolaire qui au gré des humeurs ou des
souffrances pour échanger d'élite qui
serait un coup de droite officiellement
un coup de gauche officiellement mais
qui aurait en commun de sortir toutes et
tous des mêmes écoles au fond on
voudrait réinstaller une mécanique qui
permet à des systèmes de se succéder
sans jamais être en phase avec ce que
peuple français attend mais être en
phase avec ceux qui ont pris les
habitudes de gouverner pour toujours
attendre dans la durée alors nous voyons
bien d'ailleurs qu'on joue moment nous
rassemblons
dont certains sont aux prises avec des
sujets complexes faut-il faire une
primaire ou en congrès pour désigner
notre chef c'est dire si et ce chef ne
s'impose pas d'évidence
ensuite en matière
en matière écologique
nous sommes tous convaincus que
l'écologie ne se discute pas c'est un
c'est une nécessité que d'agir sur ce
terrain là c'est une question de survie
mais ce n'est pas un dogme ce n'est pas
un dogme c'est un enjeu que nous devons
chacune et chacun avoir à l'esprit cela
doit intégrer chaque jour un peu plus
différents choix politique que nous
faisons mais ce n'est pas un dogme qui
serait somme au fonds symbole de pureté
qu'il faudrait opposé à tout autre choix
politique que celui d'une doxa qui
viendrait tout à la fois nié le réel
refuser la croissance et penser que au
fond tout dans notre société devrait
être modifier brutalement au nom des
angoisses liées au changement climatique
ou à d'autres évolutions inquiétantes
alors intégrant l'écologie mais nous
subissons jamais jamais de drogue alors
au fond dans ce contexte
dans ce contexte morcellement ici de
division un peu partout
regardons-nous en face nous qui depuis
quatre ans
travaillons ensemble
avant découvert que nos valeurs
étaient communes que nos combats étaient
communs et que surtout nos votes ont été
commun pour soutenir
l'action du président de la république
nous pouvons faire ce constat il nous
dira qu'au fond
ce que pendant des décennies et françois
l'a rappelé
le combat que vous avez menée était la
lutte contre la bipolarisation la
bipolarisation de la vie politique
française et
avec emmanuel macron a baptisé un peu
différemment
mais ça veut dire la même chose c'est le
dépassement le dépassement se veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que lorsque l'on est
d'accord sur des valeurs lorsque l'on
est d'accord sûr un projet sur une
vision d'avenir alors on va être capable
de se rassembler capable de se
rassembler quelle que soit l'origine
politique culturelle philosophique même
il n'ya pas d'appellation d'origine
contrôlée pour ceux qui veulent venir
servir la france autour du même projet
et donc
humanisme cela a été dit avant moi
justice sociale
développement économique
prises en compte total des enjeux
contemporains liés à l'écologie
évidemment impérieuse nécessité de
construire l'europe bien c'est cela qui
fait que nous sommes ensemble depuis
quatre années et que nous avons envie de
le rester
j'ajoute que nous sommes non par
contraste saisissant nous sommes dans le
refus des divisions
mais évidemment nous sommes aussi dans
la passion du départ parce qu'il faut
tout de même
faire un distinguo entre ce que sont les
divisions et la capacité à débattre
être unifiée être rassemblées ça ne veut
pas dire être dans une caserne où
personne n'aurait le droit de s'exprimer
mais la division c'est autre chose c'est
lorsque l'on mêle le désir du pouvoir
que l'on habille dans des considérants
idéologique qui en vérité ne sont que
une manière de créer des courants qui
s'opposent pour gagner la tête du parti
et croyez moi après 40 ans de parti
socialiste je n'ai vous a raconté
jusqu'à demain matin si vous y tenez
vraiment mais
que voulez vous
avant de découvrir une démarche
originale il faut avoir une solide
expérience de ce qui a existé ailleurs
aideront y compris ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le centre n'a jamais été
épargné donc
faisons
faisons de nos états de service faisons
de nos états de service des expériences
pour construire précisément un avenir
dans la clarté où l'on sait distinguer
ce qui relève des enjeux de pouvoir et
de ce qui relève des débats politiques
évitons de mélanger les deux cela
permettra aux français de s'y retrouver
un peu plus clairement alors depuis
quatre ans vient nous avons eu
l'occasion les uns et les autres et je
pense à l'ensemble aussi des militants
de la république en marche nous avons eu
l'occasion de nous connaître de nous
apprivoiser d'une certaine manière de
croiser nos cultures de voir nos points
communs
et de développer au fond ce sentiment de
confiance qui fait qu' il est temps de
faire des pas en avant vers une plus
forte unification une plus grande
capacité à construire ce que nous avons
les uns et les autres tour à tour appelé
la maison commune alors c'est vrai que
ça fait longtemps que lundi il faudrait
finir par le faire
et maintenant je lis ici ou là tiens et
il nous reparle de leurs serpents de mer
et donc qu'on se moque un peu
aujourd'hui
charitable qui ne qui aime bien ironisé
sur la lenteur des choses mais on ne
fait pas des choses aussi importantes on
ne relève pas des défis de cette
importance par un claquement de doigts
il faut d'abord y réfléchir en débattre
et puis ensuite il faut en convaincre
largement autour de soi alors moi je me
dis donnez nous un objectif
savez c'est comme quand on a un mandat
on commence quelque chose on le finit et
apprend l'inaugurent vers moi je
trouverai bien que l'on puisse inaugurer
notre maison commune avant la fin de
cette année
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment notre maison commune
pas ce doit être
une maison
savez je suis un fils de maçon
une maison aux fondations solides et
fondations c'est évidemment ce que vous
représentez et c'est ce que ça nice l'as
guérini qui sera demain parmi vous
représente c'est à dire au fond deux
organisations qui seront les piliers sur
lesquels il va être possible de bâtir de
bâtir ensemble une maison une maison
c'est pas un bunker
j'anticipe ce que les uns ou les autres
pourraient d'imaginer
c'est une belle maison avec des grandes
baies vitrées
très transparente c'est comme ça que
j'imagine avec grande pièce où on peut
débattre longtemps jeu jusqu'au bout de
la nuit si on le veut et qui soient
évidemment prête pour accueillir et pour
agir et aux fonds
qui veut ton voir venir dans notre
maison d'abord tous ceux qui à quelque
responsabilité que ce soit on fait le
quinquennat qui s'achève et qui ont
vocation à être dans cette maison
puisque ce quinquennat nous l'avons
conduit ensemble
et évidemment ses fondations cette
maison est bien l oit préparer le
quinquennat que nous espérons
est donc au-delà
évidemment de notre courant politique
qui doit être en capacité d'élargir la
majorité car la majorité que nous
représentons n'a pas vocation à se
restructurer
elle a vocation à se renforcer
et à s'élargir
ce que nous voulons c'est cela c'est
créer une maison ouverte dont nous
seront garants des fondations mais qui
ne sera fermée à personne d l'instant
évidemment nous aurons en partage les
valeurs et les projets que nous portons
et puis
françois l'a écrit dans l'éditorial
du programme je vous invite à le lire
parce que je sais très bien que ces
prêts les choses qu'on lit le plus qu'on
a tort parce que moi je voulais savoir
exactement où je venais donc j'ai dû
l'éditorial et les choses sont très très
clairement dit c'est à dire que cela
doit dépasser les échéances électorales
qui sont de rendre on ne fait pas
un parti un mouvement commun maison
commune à fond ça comme on veut
simplement pour se dire bah nous sommes
en 21 et puis à 22 2 la belle affaire
nous pourrions y aller comme nous y
sommes en 22
nous y sommes parvenus comme ça il ya
quelques années et nous avons vécu
ensemble ces quatre années non c'est
parce qu'il est urgent il est nécessaire
dans le contexte historique européen et
français
d'en créer un mouvement qui dont le
plein accomplissement dépassera ce
qu'ils auront créé et ceux qui leur ont
organisé mais qui offre à la société
française et au delà à la société
européenne qui offre un espace
où l'on peut dans cette logique de
dépassements cette logique de
rassemblement en ce refus de la
bipolarisation et qui donne une
continuité une suite une ligne d'horizon
c'est le canadien en atteint
véritablement jamais à tout ce que nous
avons en commun alors oui il faut le
faire maintenant parce que nous avons de
bonnes raisons de le faire après avoir
mûri ensemble travailler ensemble et
parce que nous avons des obstacles
extraordinairement difficile à franchir
ensemble en 2022 mais la vraie
préoccupation c'est qu'après 2022 et
vient nous soyons capacité d'attirer
toujours plus de françaises et de
français pour porter bien plus loin et
encore plus haut ce qui nous tient à
coeur c'est cela me semble-t-il ce qui
est devant nous et c'est cela l'intérêt
de cette maison commune parce que nous
avons un défi civique citoyens à relever
c'est tout de même de redonner envie aux
françaises et aux français de s'engager
et à tout le moins de voter
et donc
notre devoir
c'est de regret cette appétence
parmi notre peuple car il ya toujours
quelque chose d'un peu angoissant avoir
une démocratie
affaibli par une moindre participation
est donc au fond nous devons travailler
à définir des lignes claires a redonné
cette impression que la politique oui
peut redonner espoir et pour ma part
j'ai la conviction que là est notre
devoir et que là et le chemin que nous
avons envie de marcher ensemble en tout
cas je l'espère bonne journée
[Applaudissements]